[Music]
[Music]
do you think you can survive being stuck
in an island full of monsters and
predatory animals you could if there
were normal creatures a slim chance but
still probable sure you could scare a
tiger or wolves away with fire but what
if the island you're stuck in is skull
island and it's the one from the
monsterverse can you survive there for
at least a week before a rescue team
arrives and take you back to
civilization so here in this video we
will dive into what it takes for you to
keep safe till help arrives in skull
island and at the same time discuss the
monsters that are out there to kill you
and also survival techniques so
subscribe if you haven't already and now
let's get to it
let us first understand where skull
island is and how you could probably be
shipwrecked in that monstrous place
well since we are looking at the version
from the master verse it will not be
situated in the southern part of the
indian ocean but rather in the middle of
the pacific ocean
four thousand kilometers away from
hawaii in the northwest at the same
distance away from the mexican coast in
the north east of it and about four
thousand kilometers away from either
south america
antarctica
or the micronesian islands so there is
no way to send smoke signals for help or
any kind of sos ships won't be passing
through there anyway but luckily you
have a satellite phone that's just you
know how you could get out let's just
give you something hope
you could use that to call for rescue
but it'll take seven days
so how do you survive for a week in that
island
first and foremost you have to know what
are the dangerous creatures of skull
island then and only then can you
strategize a way to get through without
losing your limbs or your head
so what are the ones that are
herbivorous and benign and which ones
are after you the second you step into
that island
the harmless ones are small creatures
like the deers fern birds squirrels
and water buffaloes even the big
creatures like the triceratops the magma
turtles the skirt buffaloes and spore
mantises will not be harmful if you keep
out of their way these after all are
well and territorial creatures
protective of their young and
apprehensive of squiggly little humans
but what are the really dangerous
creatures
firstly from the air you have swarms of
leaf wings and psycho vultures that will
hunt you down and rip you to shreds if
they ever get you out in the open fields
or open space
in the swamps there are huge monstrous
siren jaws
and ambush predators like the vine
stranglers and swarm locusts
that are more than 25 feet long
in the forest there are huge spirit
tigers that will hunt you down before
you even know that they are there
there are packs of ravenous death
jackals that will relentlessly pursue
you and
you will have also mother long legs that
will stop unwitting prey amongst the
bamboo groves
even in the rivers there are these
gigantic maya squids and strange snake
squids
but the most dangerous of all are the
skull crawlers they can smell you from a
mile away and are always starving for
food so how does one navigate the island
and survive is it even possible
well as you can see from the movie
the two world war ii pilots gunpei ikari
and marlow managed to survive and even
find shelter among the eewee natives of
the place and yes even the natives the
eevee people have managed to carve out a
space for themselves to call home a safe
space for shelter and to thrive in
but this is partly due to their
allegiances to the king of the island
gong
which you will barely get any help from
since you'll you'll already be dead even
before you know where to look for him
but the thing is yes you can survive for
a few days or weeks in the island given
that you know what to do out there what
the dangerous things are and where these
dangerous creatures are located in
okay what are the five things you need
to do in order to live
you need to be invisible you need to
know where to be which is location you
need food and water sustenance you need
warmth and shelter and lastly you need
some sort of weapon to defend yourself
from threats or at least to deter them
from coming towards you
so first and foremost you have to be
invisible of course by that i don't mean
being literally invisible like the
hollow man but what i mean is that you
should not be seen hurt or even smell
you need to be extra quiet and not shout
out for help since there won't be any in
the first place any sound you make will
attract unwanted attention so move like
a cat in the corners and stay less
visible of course cover yourself with
leaves and camouflage yourself then at
the same time mask your scent with mud
or other pungent vegetation just to
minimize the smell of sweat coming out
of you
but that won't be enough you need to get
to a safer place from where you are
right now which would mean that you need
to know the geography of the island
the important thing you need to know is
bigger life forms tend to stay in the
center of the island and the nearer you
are to the coast the safer you would be
that's from jurassic park part three but
it's the same
skull island is filled with lush jungles
all over the place
there are these grasslands and lots of
mountains in the center of the place
even forests so you need to avoid these
and try as much as you can to traverse
through the harsh coastline and find a
spot where it is less forested and has
ample space for you to run away in in
the case a predator comes your way the
best is near cliffs but not necessarily
the cliffs more like near them
and avoid being too close to the water
as well there are dangerous creatures
like the maya squids there
next in order to survive and stay alive
for a week you need to build a crude
shelter with some sort of basic
fortifications
then focus on finding food and fresh
drinking water a small cave or a human
sized hole in the rocks would suffice
since you'll be out in a week you need
not concern yourself in building
something extravagant the truth about
survival in this place isn't being on
the top of the food chain but to be
unnoticeable
you should lower your standards and lift
like gollum from the lord of the rings a
dark and dingy place grubs for food and
on occasion try to catch a fish and
small birds but most importantly no
matter how thirsty you are ocean water
is a no-no
coconut water is okay or locating a
small stream is vital it's hot and humid
out there hydration is essential
now that you are done with finding
shelter in a small crevice or a hole not
necessarily a large cave as bigger
predators would easily enter these
places and have a banquet with your head
on the main dish you need to make
weapons to defend yourself or at least
the entrance and also flush out the
smaller threats that might be with you
in that hole what kind of weapons can
you make or find so given the fact that
you're stranded you would probably have
no gun with you and yes even if you do
it should be the last resort since a
sound of a gunshot will give away your
position and skull crawlers will come
one gunshot is dangerous too will
definitely tell every predator out there
where you are
so you should fashion yourself a crude
spear from whatever tree branch you can
find and strap a sharpened rock at the
tip to act as a spear tip dig yourself
in and face the tip outwards also you
can make a few spiked barricades if you
have time and a shield or a dough to
cover the entrance the thing is to be
well hidden
of course even with all this there is no
100 chance that you will get out alive
but it does improve your survival rate
barricading yourself in a hole with
bikes and basic doors or a kind of a
frame will deter predators that might
lurk into the coastlines since catching
you and dragging you out will expend
more energy than whatever nutrition your
body will provide them
they will most probably move on and find
other prey the last thing you need to do
is to radio in your position
giving landmarks as clues to your
location and telling them that you're at
least 300 meters away from a smoke
signal you shouldn't be seen in the open
with a smoke signal predators will just
come on and just snatch you out
[Music]
yeah smoke signals should be made before
their arrival the thing about evacuation
in the island is that this is one of the
most dangerous moments any delay in
getting out means your position is given
away the rescue team would be in danger
themselves and a second attempt would
almost be useless
so there you go the important things you
need to know in order to survive on
skull island for some time
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family and smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam